auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge familie almeyda wandert aus in
drei stunden geht der flieger nach
kanada
im osten kanadas sucht familie almeyda
aus dem kanton zürich die ruhe
sie übernimmt ein altes modell vom
emmental nach uruguay rudi und susann
althaus sieht es nach südamerika dort
bauen sie eigenhändig eine ferien und an
der nordsee eröffnet familie kunz einen
imbiss mit pommes und currywurst starten
die baselbieter in ein neues leben
[Musik]
das haus in läufelfingen hat familie
kunst verkauft schon in ein paar wochen
stehen vaters schauen von calvin
gemeinsam hinter dem grill im
imbisswagen antworten mehr so die idee
der lakis absicherungs und schöne ist
dass man das ganze familie könnt und
danke das ist sehr schön und sehr
skeptisch zeigen
das lauftraining moritz nitsche und dann
mit tanja überlegt so eigentlich
entwickelt apps premier der
touristenmagnet den umzug an die nordsee
stimmt die fünfköpfige familie selber
ohne zügel unternehmen das spart geld
großmutter susan sieht mit in den norden
sie will nach ihren enkeln timo und
noemi schauen während die eltern im
imbisswagen arbeiten ist schwierig danke
ich mir ja darum den ganztag wackeln
weil man sowieso und auch auf jeden fall
freuen
made in austria werden und braucht dass
ich es auch nebenan sortieren mutter
brigitte und tochter noemi sportkleidung
aus
der cheerleading verein in basel war bis
jetzt neue miss ein und alles
ich war vor enix recht denke ich kontakt
gestanden der zwei wochen gesehen dass
ich sie schon fünf trainings gesehen und
haben eine zwei mal übernachtet das
läuft
nur das nötigste kommt mit ins neue heim
[Musik]
das alte sofa jedenfalls bleibt hier die
ganze wohnzimmer einrichtung wollen sie
in norddeutschland neu kaufen
denn verbleibenden hausrat bringen sie
zur großmutter sie wohnt nur ein paar
hundert meter weiter in ihrem haus hat
es genügend platz bis zur abreise in
sieben wochen kommt die ganze familie
hier unter samt katze roxy und front
fall corp
[Musik]
doch sind sie hier nur in den ferien das
aber schon zum zehnten mal in ein paar
monaten werden rudi althaus und seine
frau susan der schweiz zu sagen
in uruguay wollen sich die emmentaler
eine neue existenz aufbauen
unweit des río de la plata einen strom
der bis zum horizont reicht
dann ist keine luft
rimini street
ein ganzer strauß vgl
vom menschenleeren strand ins zentrum
von colonia del sacramento sind es mit
dem auto nur zehn minuten
die älteste stadt europas ist ein
beliebtes ausflugsziel
auch bei den zukünftigen auswanderern
[Musik]
was für rudi und susann mit ferien
begann entwickelte sich über die letzten
drei jahre zu einem projekt für die
zweite lebenshälfte
[Musik]
jetzt treiben sie ihren traum voran
den ersten termin haben sie mit
architektin jimena und maklerin
alexandra alexandra wuchs in uruguay auf
ihre eltern sind deutsche sie ist
bestens vernetzt und hilft einwanderern
bei den ersten schritten im frühjahr
2016 hatte sie ruhe die un susan ein
stück land gezeigt dass die beiden kurz
entschlossen kauften noch ohne konkreten
plan
das grundstück ist fünf hektar groß so
fiel wie sieben fußballfelder
die beiden wollen eine passage bauen
eine art ferien lodge mit fünf häusern
restaurant und swimmingpool
als gelernter schreiner möchte ich so
viel wie möglich selber machen gemeinsam
arktis mache ja ich hab's kates mit das
thema ist mir das zimmer erschaffen und
dann keine kraft dort ist ja manchmal
kommen nur mit
für das land haben sie bereits rund
100000 franken investiert und der bau
der lodge kostet sie noch einiges mehr
wie vor rudy und susann nach uruguay
ziehen soll bauunternehmer maurizio das
land erschließen
architektin regina hat ihn vermittelt
der bauunternehmer will den beiden so
schnell wie möglich seine offerte
schicken
[Musik]
familie almeida aus dem kanton zürich
nimmt jeden tag ein wenig abschied von
der schweiz
rubin andré und sophie gehen heute ein
letztes mal mit ihren eltern in den
freizeitpark
für familie an mai da ist die zeit reif
für neue abenteuer
schon in einer woche geht es los der 46
jährige josef übernimmt zusammen mit
seiner frau beatrix ein altes modell in
der kanadischen provinz
[Musik]
mai das waren vor zwei jahren zum ersten
mal in kanada
es gefiel ihnen gleich so gut dass sie
sich spontan ein ferienhaus kauften
seitdem ließ sie das land nicht mehr los
jetzt wieder bewusst wird
aber die haustechnik realisiert dass ich
ihren hof hinter mir lernen hoch verbot
die freunde und ganz tibet segen
eigentlich dass hund und selber schon
wieder etwas neues wagen und das leben
noch einmal anders ausrichten
an dieser idee fand auch die 41-jährige
beatrice nach und nach gefallen
seit zehn jahren hält die beiden hier
bei dem breakfast ständig auf trab
ruhe und mehr zeit mit den kindern das
erhoffen sich die almeyda in kanada
[Musik]
läufelfingen im baselbiet bis zur
abreise nach norddeutschland und familie
kunst bei crivitz mutter susan seinen
job im außendienst hat sascha schon
aufgegeben
zum saisonende gibt er auch seinen
posten als fußball trainer ab zweimal
pro woche trainiert der 50 jährige eine
junioren mannschaft schon timo nimmt
dann immer mit
[Musik]
in läufelfingen fühlte sich sascha
eigentlich wohl
er hatte für die familie ein schönes
haus hatte freunde und war in fußballer
kreisen geschätzt
nur sein job als vertreter machte ihm
zunehmend kopfzerbrechen
[Musik]
mehr hintergrund sehr viel und das wird
sicher nicht so einfach fallen aber doch
das natürlich ein scherz doch die
letzten zusagen zentrums letzten jahren
toll sie im beruflichen bereich aber das
ist einfach sehr scharf und das hätte
jetzt einfach klar und das war es jetzt
50.000 kilometer vor sascha pro jahr
hätte von kunde zu kunde an der nordsee
werte von frühling bis herbst an der
fritteuse stehen
[Musik]
wie blick
sein bruder erlebt
die liebe zum fußball wo es ja bereits
in die wiege gelegt sein vater war
profifußballer beim fc basel
der großvater ein bekannter
schiedsrichter sascha selbst war
jahrelang torhüter und danach trainer
wir haben jetzt entweder führt aus und
liegt jetzt eben sprechen wenn ich habe
sowieso nie stellen und aber es geht ja
der fußball als wert vielleicht aber der
beruf geschafft
das ist jetzt wichtig dass man sich
einfach verlockend dass wir jetzt nicht
mehr machen wollte
[Musik]
das neue läden in norddeutschland ist
für sascha und seine familie schon zum
greifen nah
[Musik]
nächster termin in uruguay architektin
regina die skizzen die ruhe die von der
pousada gezeichnet hat überarbeitet
[Gelächter]
erste änderungen hat kemena am
restaurant und der rezeption vorgenommen
sie schlägt vor dort glastüren
einzubauen und hatte man dieses kleine
fenster guckt nicht richtig was du
willst du hast dann kannst du dies nun
so ich muss sagen die stones nicht aus
gold sowohl die weiß wie man baut aber
den stil der gebäude überlässt er den
frauen mit hilfe des st
wir bewahren großen fehler praktisch
immer denke er denkt noch praktischer
aber manchmal ist die ästhetik sie
gemacht
[Musik]
die weite die ruhe und die menschen
haben es susanne und rudi angetan
aber nicht nur für sie ist das
vermeintliche paradies
auch andere schweizer hat es hierher
verschlagen
die schweizer und ihr ausbreiten und
haben das paris aus wie so oft bei den
bogenschützen hier relativ lang hat das
wolfgang
die bündner rinne und sonja topaz sind
da wo odeon susan noch hinwollen
seit über 20 jahren betreiben sie ein
kleines gästehaus seine erfahrungen vom
leben in der südamerikanischen pampa
teil trainer gerne
[Musik]
6 uhr 30 in der früh noch ist alltag in
der casa almeyda in turbenthal der 30
übernimmt die kinder ehemann josef
bereitet mit großmutter tina das
frühstück für die gäste vor bis zu zwölf
gäste können josef und beatrice in ihrem
bett and breakfast beherbergen
tina ist am vortag mit ihrem
lebenspartner hier eingezogen
sie ist pensioniert und wird nach der
abreise der familie den gäste betrieb
übernehmen ihr serien ist seit jahren an
der hatz honig brotaufstrich kennt ihr
schokolade für die milch möchte jemand
von euch gern gekocht ist
fünf minuten also zwei aufstiegen
trotz neue aufgabe es fällt ihm schwer
die familie ziehen zu lassen
ich bin aus meinen eltern komplett
meistens muss ich hier bis sie in kanada
heimisch geworden sind wurden die an
meyers das bed and breakfast noch
behalten und das spezielle gedanken
hatte ich ganz krumm ist
[Musik]
wattenmeer krabbenkutter und strandkörbe
dazu nicht selten eine steife brise
[Musik]
für viele auswanderer wäre die raue
nordsee das letzte was sie sich
vorstellen könnten wirklich sehr lang
und hat uns immer gesagt dass wir
irgendein romane und jetzt setzt sich
einfach die baselbieter haben drei tage
zeit um in norddeutschland alles für das
neue leben vorzubereiten
dafür hat sich bringt extra freigenommen
noch arbeitet sie teilzeit als
verkäuferin in einem sportgeschäft
[Musik]
mit oder ohne
es braucht aber immer gedanken wenn der
verschiedenen das lager schon jahre
gesetzt einige tipps offiziell geschafft
haben wir haben
[Musik]
sieben tage in der woche werden sascha
und prix geht während der saison hinter
dem verkaufstresen stehen diese
vorstellung aber schreckt sie nicht
obwohl sie bisher kaum gastronomie
erfahrung haben
[Musik]
frisch gestärkt geht es zum möbelkauf
nach den langen arbeitstagen im
imbisswagen wollen sie auf ein bequemes
sofa nicht verzichten
schlussendlich ich glaube aber dass wir
haben so schnell wie möglich
naja beträge dem soziologen und operiere
gesprochen christa thoben cdu sind wenn
man einen stoff nimmt wie sieht das
einstand und der lieferfrist und so wie
es hier steht geht das dann auch so
lange weil wir können nicht mehr so
lange ja ok foto kasiewicz glaubt es ist
so
[Musik]
so war gut alles gut
in odenthal in der casa almeyda haben
die gäste ausgecheckt josef zeigt seiner
mutter tina auf was sie zukünftig alles
achten muss die arbeit im bed and
breakfast ist für tina nicht wirklich
neu sie hatte ihren sohn während der
ferien schon ein paar mal vertreten
bert respekt unterdessen 300 anis
kürzlich ein letzter auftrag für eine
kirchengemeinde die produktion des
gebäcks ist das zweite standbein von
familie almeyda neben dem gästebetrieb
ich hoffe es klappt nicht machen
ganz loslassen kann beatrice aber noch
nicht im herbst will sie für einige
wochen wieder in ihre backstube
zurückkehren und die kurze auf
verschiedenen märkten verkaufen
betten beziehen zimmer putzen waschen
jeden tag aufs neue
aber selbstbewusster gemacht
der hersteller gar keine ferien
mannschaft am wochenende auf der a40
und das jetzt in cannes hat auch schon
anders mit den angestellten anstrengend
ist verbraucht musst du und ich kann
auch noch im netz verbringen heißt es
muss wirklich perfekt sie da ist die
schweiz
sie will ihr programm
da muss nur mal ein bett warum groß sind
zusätzlich zwischen einem und vier
betten können gäste buchen je nach
zimmer dem so die route jetzt da wir
momentan in puschkin tut als wäre mir
gewesen
[Musik]
sie hat sich verlobt da sind drei
personen ohne beute aber das ist kein
problem dass zwei minuten arbeiten
sie ist halt noch nicht so sattelfest
und es ist ganz wichtig dass man das
richtig macht will das thema zum
beispiel als privat sport und dass sie
dann erhöht oder und ludwig und nachher
eine überraschung und eine schlechte
bewertung über wurde und das hat man
auch in kanada dritter sind als immer
einheitlich zwischen vorteil haus wurde
in einer woche muss tina alleine
klarkommen
josef bleibt nicht mehr viel zeit seine
mutter vollends ins geschäft mit den
gästen einzuführen
der blick aufs wattenmeer gehört für
sascha und prix geht bald zum
arbeitsalltag
denn direkt am kutterhafen steht der
imbisswagen denn die baselbieter
übernehmen wollen
nach dorum einer ortschaft mit rund 3500
einwohnern sind es nur ein paar
kilometer
hier haben sich sascha und bringt ein
günstiges haus mit drei wohnungen
gekauft zwei jahre stand es leer
[Musik]
inzwischen sind machte dass wir alle
merken mit dem schrieben dass nach dem
kauf haben sie das haus selber renoviert
alte möbel entsorgt tapeten abgelöst und
die wände neu gestrichen
für böden und bäder haben sie handwerker
beauftragt das bad entpuppte sich als
große baustelle ist sehr viel größer
hätte und quasi den abbau leitung
übernommen hätte das ganze soll eine
koordiniert und da hat er super ein
glücksfall denn ohne die hilfe des
nachbarn wäre die wohnung längst noch
nicht fertig einen stock höher sind zwei
weitere wohnungen sohn kevin soll das
kleine appartement beziehen haben wir
trotzdem große darauf dass einen
winterschlaf machen denn sie halten
alles mit ihnen machen
die große wohnung nebenan haben sie für
credits mutter susan hergerichtet sie
kommt mit nach dorum
wir sind sehr froh ein kult um zu sehen
dass ich immer ganz klar ich aber
trotzdem eine stuntfrau das ist mehr
kein problem aber so ist doch viel
besser
[Musik]
nochmals gelang es dann geschafft
bald ist alles bereit für den einzug
[Musik]
fehlt nur noch das abschiedsfest
dann hält sascha und prix geht nichts
mehr in der schweiz
[Musik]
in uruguay wurden rudi und susanne
erkunden woher sie das baumaterial für
ihre busacca bekommen grüne tobler
übersetzen
der 53-jährige ruhe die hat zu hause im
emmental bereits eine liste erstellt mit
allem was er zum bauen braucht
anderthalb jahre geben sie sich zeit
dann müssen sie ihr steak estelle
beherbergen
[Musik]
ich musste wieder unter 7 hört
aber das 1
steigern
erster stopp ein eisenwarenladen ruhe
die möchte ganz bestimmte schrauben was
es hier nicht gibt müssten die
auswanderer im container aus der schweiz
mitbringen
weiter geht's zum sägewerk
sie suchen holz für die decke der fünf
gästehäuser
[Musik]
gut bringen
ja das hat was dagegen ist einfach schon
mal scheinen ja
rudi hat die holzverarbeitung im blut er
wuchs in einem schreiner betrieb auf den
einst sein großvater gegründet hatte die
beiden sind einen großen schritt weiter
in gut vier monaten wollen sie mit dem
bau beginnen
nach einer kurzen nacht ist es in
turbenthal soweit in drei stunden geht
der flieger nach kanada allem eins
nehmen so wenig wie möglich mit die
wichtigsten dinge haben sie in 14 koffer
gepackt oder bereits per post nach
kanada verschickt
ich bin das ganze umfeld ständig zu
prüfen
jetzt ein bewusst das ist großmutter
tina bereitet sandwiches vor
für die lange reise gleich muss sie
ihren enkeln goodbye sagen
das ist logisch
[Musik]
das ist es aber immer schwerer
aber das haben wir die mittel gibt es
nicht
[Musik]
über 5000 kilometer sind es bis halifax
noch einmal ganz fest drücken fast 24
stunden wird die familie nach kanada
unterwegs sein
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge rotieren zu sand
sind zurück im emmental und räumen ihr
haus chemischen abschied nehmen von
ihren drei schönen sascha und brechen
mit sack und pack nach norddeutschland
auf der imbisswagen am kutterhafen
wartet auf die neuen besitzer aus der
schweiz und motel besichtigung in kanada
beatrice beschleichen leichte zweifel da
ist ein riss im dach
[Musik]
muss ich die gerne mit
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge